moi je vais vous donner des conseils de
films qui m'ont marqué qui m'ont
beaucoup plu
déjà le premier film auquel je pense
c'est little big man c'est un jeune
américain de 1970 de l'arthur peine
c'était le régulateur de bonnie and
clyde on retrouve dans le film
daste enough en effet y ait de louey
c'est un western et c'est un western qui
bouleverse le genre puisque les indiens
ne sont pas vus comme des sauvages
dans ce film ils sont venus au contraire
des victimes de la conquête de l'ouest
est donc l'histoire du film on suit
l'histoire de jack crabe en 1970 jack
rabat 121 ans et ils racontent toute son
histoire et c'est intéressant parce que
c'est un jeune en blanc qui va être
élevé par des cheyennes qui va ensuite
devenir le roi de la gâchette qui va
ensuite participé aux grandes batailles
little big horn et couple y est donc en
1977 et une critique flagrante de la
guerre du vietnam
donc c'est un film qui est à la fois
drôle et émouvant et moi je le conseille
de le voir en version française puisque
ça rajoute une touche
d'humour supplémentaires la vf est assez
drôle
voilà donc c'est little big man avec
dustin hoffman mon autre conseil c'est
était une fois en amérique c'est aussi
un film américain c'est aussi une grande
fresque sur l'histoire de l'amérique
puisque c'est un film qui date de 1984
qui a été réalisé par sergio leone avec
un robert de niro
c'est d'ailleurs le tout dernier film de
sergio leone et on va suivre l'histoire
de noodles joué par de niro de la
prohibition jusqu'aux années 60 dont 45
ans de cette histoire de ce mafieux du
ghetto juif sa décadence et la grande
histoire avec ses amis mafieux sergio
leone s'est encore fait accompagner par
un humour écoles on retire la musique
notamment grandiose le film a été
restauré en 2012
il est ressorti à cannes à ce moment là
qu'est il ya des scènes rajoutées ces
décès n'ont jamais eu des scènes
inédites
elles ont été retrouvées sur un support
un peu particulier et ils n'ont pas
réussi à les restaurer la même manière
donc quand on voit la version actuelle
du film il y à des scènes qui sont
beaucoup plus moche et qui en français
ne sont pas doublés donc c'est le destin
qui ne sont en vo avec une qualité de
soins de qualité d'image de couleurs qui
sont vraiment différents c'était donc il
était une fois en amérique de sergio
leone
c'est les deux conseils que je vous
donnais mais vous aussi vous orienter
sur le site du cnc le cnc le centre
national du cinéma qui gère le cinéma
les films les salles de cinéma etc et
ils jouent à moteur de référencement
pour les la vidéo à distance
il y à toutes les offres légales
évidemment pour voir des films à la
demande et pour les enfants je ne
saurais que vous conseiller d'aller voir
le site banshee et e n shq banshee point
fr et accès à des fiches
d'accompagnement des films il y as et
conseils de films pour les tranches
d'âge de 3 à 10 ans et il ya une partie
payante qui est la vidéo à la demande ou
tous les défis qui sont sélectionnés qui
sont des courts métrages de longs
métrages et vous pouvez laisser vos
enfants tranquillement là dessus puisque
vous êtes pour toute sécurité donc c'est
benji point fr tous ces autres et cela
je les mettrai sur le site du cinéma
cinémas grenier à sel point fr